WESLEY CHUN: Howdy, developers.
Some of you are
probably wondering
why I'm wearing a mask that
looks like a grassy field.
Well, that's the subject of
today's video, field masks.
Love the mask, but it makes
it hard for me to talk to you.
Hi, I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
And welcome to another episode
of the G Suite Dev show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: While we do
look at several G Suite
APIs in this video,
field masks are general
and apply across Google
APIs, from YouTube
to the Google Cloud Platform.
So what are field masks?
Well, they're not
masks that you wear.
The best way to think
of them is as a filter.
While they work
differently when reading
data from, versus
writing data to, an API,
the filter analogy is
still the most appropriate.
So why discuss field masks?
Well, they're not the most
straightforward feature,
and can be confusing for some.
Because the docs
are often terse,
it may not be clear as to what
they do or how to use them.
So we're going to
clear the air so you
can hit the ground running.
Let's start with read.
When making an API call
to get information,
response sizes
vary between APIs.
Some return just
a trickle of data
while others give you an ocean.
If you're using a particularly
verbose API, this can add up.
Field masks can help control the
amount of data that comes back.
This is commonly referred
to as partial response
in the documentation.
Let's look at a few examples
from various Google APIs,
starting with Gmail.
In another video,
I show users how
to use the Gmail API to
update email signatures.
To change a user
signature, you need
to loop through
all email addresses
to find the ones
you want to change.
If you're changing just
the primary signature,
you need the isPrimary flag too.
Both are part of the send
as array return in the API
response you see here, along
with plenty other fields
we don't need.
To tell the API that those
are the only fields we
want, specify them as
comma separated parent
slash child fields.
An alternative
shortcut is to group
the children with parentheses,
making it a bit easier to read.
Either way, this instructs the
API to drop all other fields.
Well, to see what it
looks like in real life,
here's some pseudo code.
Well, OK, it's actual Python.
The snippet displays all
of your email addresses
and flags your primary
address with a P.
We drop in the fields parameter
just like how we drew it up
on the previous slide.
Also see the Gmail API docs
page on partial response.
Moving on.
In another video,
we showed you how
to display the first 100 files
and folders in your Google
Drive, but didn't
filter the response.
In a bit, we'll see how this
impacts performance in terms
of both space and time.
For now we can use these field
mask values so only the IDs,
file names, and MIME types
come back in the response.
As before, we can also
group with parentheses.
Here's a Python code that uses
field masks to get and display
these three fields for
each of the 100 files.
The Drive API docs
also has a page
on partial response and other
good performance practices.
Before leaving this
example, I want
to share the results of a
little test I ran with the Drive
version to API without fields,
like the call you see here,
and then run it again,
but with fields.
Guess what?
The payload for the
data for all 100 files
comes in at 242k,
almost 16 times
the 15K used when getting
just the IDs, file
names, and MIME types, saving
about 94% in memory cost.
Similarly, executing
the API call with fields
took just 144 milliseconds,
almost three times faster
than the 554 needed
for all of the data.
It wasn't a rigorous study,
but gives you a rough idea
as to what field masks can do.
If the API payload
is small, the server
doesn't have much work to do to
throw those responses together.
But on the other hand, if
it has to assemble a car,
you've got some extra overhead.
Why should you incur
additional network costs
and negatively impact latency
for data you don't need?
Making some sense now?
For the last demo, we'll
fetch a spreadsheet's name
plus the names and IDs of
each of the individual sheets.
This example is a bit more
complex than the first pair
as the values are
in different fields,
as you can see from
the get response.
This time, the full paths down
to each field are too long.
We can do some parenthetical
grouping, but in the end
you're going to have
a mix and can't really
get it shorter than this.
Here's the corresponding
Python snippet
that does what we want with
the help of field masks.
There's also a partial response
page in the sheet's API docs.
You got the hang of it now?
Well, that was
reading from an API.
In part two, we'll look at
writing data with field masks,
as well as share some best
practices for both read
and write.
Find out more about partial
response from this page
in the client library docs.
The field masks guides
in the Slides API docs
is the most comprehensive,
covering read and write.
So check it out to get a
preview before the next video.
And the last link takes you to
more episodes of the G Suite
Dev Show.
Well, that's it for today.
Now that we took the mystery
out of using them for read API
calls, it's time for you
to put on your field mask
and cut down on your
API response payloads.
Be sure to tune into part
two of our two-part series
to learn more about using field
masks with right API calls
and subscribe to our channel.
This is, Wesley Chun, and we'll
see you the next time on the G
Suite Dev Show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]